Gary Johnson was the Republican governor
New Mexico from 1995 to 2003 and is now
running for president of the United
States as a libertarian we have a lot to
get to in a short amount of time
governor nice to see Dave great to be
with you so and I'm seeking the
libertarian nomination and the
libertarian nominee will be on the
ballot in all 50 states so really the
libertarian nominee is the legitimate
third party all right well I'm glad to
hear that and we just talked a lot of
this out in the green room and we're in
a time situation here that might work
that's why we running said there's a lot
I want to talk to you about because as I
told you a few minutes ago I've had a
lot of my audience and AH Dave's gonna
come out as a libertarian one of these
days you know I've sort of evolved out
of this progressive thing and they want
me to say it so I'm gonna let you sell
it so sell me on libertarianism give me
libertarianism 101
well libertarian just what I say with a
broad brushstroke libertarians are
fiscally responsible and socially
liberal if you look up the definition of
a classic liberal if you Wikipedia
classic liberal I'm a classic liberal
great and I think most people fall in
that category right now there's a
website i side with calm in 2012 that
was also online i side with and most of
the people that took that test aligned
with me and so most people in this
country are at actually classical
liberals are i think they are
libertarian they just don't know it so
what's actually the difference between
classical liberal because that's really
where where i would say i'm at right
this very moment I mean when I was when
I was 12 I remember wanting Michael
Dukakis to win I've always thought I was
a liberal and then I sort of went down
the progressive route but now I see sort
of less government as a sensible or a
tournament so what's the difference
between classical liberal and
libertarian I don't know is there a
difference oh yeah that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying I'm saying
that I think they are speaking with a
broad brushstroke one on same right yeah
so and classical liberal is actually
considered a conservative principle
right which seems which is I mean that's
how it all started right that's how it
all started out but the
the Conservatives have lost their way in
my opinion with a social conservative
agenda that I think turns a lot of
people off and rightfully so it doesn't
allow people to make their own personal
choices recognize their own personal
liberties and freedoms and of course the
responsibility that goes along with that
right so on two of the things that are
the easy ones like gay marriage and
recreational or even medicinal marijuana
easy thing for you it this is an easy
thing right because you want limited
government so it doesn't matter yeah
it's not a woman's right to choose I
mean throw that in there just basic
decisions you as an individual should be
the only one I mean these are difficult
I don't want to say that marriage
equality is a difficult personal choice
but you know take abortion for example I
mean that's a difficult issue but who
who but the woman involved should be
making that choice right so what
happened then to the Republican Party
that should be for small government and
should really be for states rights the
things that I think you're saying you're
for what happened to them that they got
mucked up in these issues that really
they should be I don't know but they
certainly have gotten mucked up in my
opinion yeah and with regard to
Republicans look they've always hung
their hat on being fiscally conservative
well where did that go I mean they want
to cut spending in social areas but they
want to increase spending when it comes
to the military they got they are
they're growing government just like
Democrats so is that is that the
dangerous thing more than anything else
that the one guy who was talking about
making government smaller in this entire
election cycle was Rand Paul he didn't
even get out of the Iowa caucus I agree
and I think that Rand Paul really if he
wasn't a social conservative I think
there would have been a lot more appeal
I happen to agree with half of
everything that Rand Paul has to say
right but when it comes to those social
issues that's where we part ways right
so he soared he just won't absolute say
that he's for gay marriage or formulas
he'll say let the state's decide that
but personally he would say that no he's
opposed to these issues well personally
I'm not opposed
allowing a person to make these choices
believing in my heart of hearts that
these are decisions that only the person
involves should be making right so then
does that right there go to how
dysfunctional our system is which
probably explains why Bernie and Trump
are working because those are the sorts
so the system right now is the
Republican nominee has to cater to 30%
of the far-right right so that's what
the Republican nominee is appealing to
30% far-right the Democrat nominee is
appealing to 30% of the far left when
you have 45% of the electorate declaring
themselves as independent what you end
up with the two major candidates is a
solid 30 percent representation of the
electorate which is really nuts okay I'm
with you so your cell job is working so
far I'm fully with you so what do we do
to explain to people I think people
think when you say to someone you're a
libertarian I think they think you want
to dismantle the government you want
people to run around only defending
themselves and roads are going to
crumble because the government won't be
able to sustain them they're crumbling
anyway even though the government's
involved so what do you do to remove
some of the stigma from libertarians
well I got to serve as governor of New
Mexico for eight years and guess what I
think things worked a lot better and in
a state that was two-to-one Democrat and
and having gotten reelected the second
time by a bigger margin and the first
time yeah are you a Republican though
but you were using a lot of libertarian
principles I was always the finger was
always pointing at me saying well really
he's a libertarian which I always
thought was a real compliment right and
I still do to this day because it's a
lot more clear you know where a
libertarian stands when it comes to all
the issues I remember growing up getting
this book on here's where a very short
book on here's where this is what a
libertarian is and I remember saying I'm
a libertarian and this was I want to say
I was 14 or 15 years old wow I'm a
libertarian yeah well I remember when I
was contemplating running for governor
of New Mexico I showed up at the state
libertarian meeting and it took me about
45 seconds to come to grips with
fact that I would never hold office if I
ran as a libertarian so what was that
about well just the fact that really
disorganized there aren't many
libertarians but that isn't to say the
libertarians aren't principally correct
and libertarianism is really all
principled and yes less government is
better the biggest issue facing our
country right now I think is the fact
that we continue to spend more money
than what we take in and the
ramifications of this at some point is
going to be a monetary collapse and
that's going to be ugly
really really really ugly yeah so I know
a ton of my supporters are ton of my
fans are Bernie supporters and I like
Bernie I think he's talking about the
right things but you know this idea that
college is free and the rest of this
stuff you would argue that these things
simply aren't free and the government
probably shouldn't have anything to do
with them so half of what Bernie says
Wow right on spot-on right so your
campaign finance and things like that
well campaign finance and back to
individuals making choices in their own
lives and and that there is a corporate
America the crony capitalism is alive
and well I recognized that spot on but
then it but then when he starts talking
about spending and what government
should provide and expand a huge
gigantic expansion of government it's
just not possible Dave I mean I'm in the
camp that believes that there will be a
monetary collapse and it will be because
of inflation and it'll be a bond market
collapse because nobody will be holding
on to bonds because inflation will be
rising at such a rate that bonds won't
be anything that you'll want to hold on
to because basically the government is
just going to spend in spend and spend
and spend old are intact buy goods
backed by nothing and people then
recognize it and like I say if you get
into hyperinflation which in my opinion
at some point will be the conclusion to
all of this you're not going to hold on
to a bond when it may be devaluing at
the rate of you know many percentage
points a day you're just not going to
hold on
to it yeah so is that's a bond market
collapse right so is part of the problem
then that what you just explained to me
that that sort of lofty stuff to be
talking about it is it is but it but but
but it is out there also and how do you
how do you make that as simple as
possible a monetary collapse is when the
dollars that you have don't buy a thing
so let's try and just define it in
reality you're not going to be able to
buy anything at the grocery store
because there'll be nothing on the
shelves people will have recognized that
you've got to take all the money that
you have and buy everything that you
possibly can because it's not going to
be worth anything tomorrow right that's
a monetary collapse that has that is
something that's repeated itself in
countries time and time over the history
of mankind right so this is what immune
from that so that's sort of like what
happened in Greece like a year ago and
then everyone rushes to the banks then
the banks don't let you have to happened
in Russia happened in Zimbabwe like I
say this at some point in my opinion is
going to be the outcome of all this so
is part of the problem messaging then
because on one hand I see Bernie going
here's free college that's great young
people go that free college sounds great
and then you have Trump go you know just
throwing out of this red meat about
Muslims or immigration or whatever it is
like they're just giving easy answers
what you just talked about about making
government smaller and bonds and our and
our monetary system that's you know we
need a better bumper sticker for that
kind of stuff right right and it doesn't
quite fit into a sound bite doesn't
quite fit into a sound bite but but
liberty freedom personal responsibility
be John Stuart Mill right well being
conservative the way that we live our
own lives you know I wish I could spend
the way the government does would that
be sweet well you you would know that a
little while right for a couple years if
you never had to pay it back yeah yeah
if you could get away with that kind of
a Ponzi scheme but you you know you're
not gonna get away with it
nor is the government so what is the
we're trying to pack in or out here in a
little minute yes um thank you got a job
yeah so what is the libertarian view on
foreign policy because one of the
interesting things that I
being in the GOP debates is that these
guys are all very to the right like we
don't talk about nation-building anymore
but there's still a lot of talk about
war and bombing and Rand was the one guy
that was saying maybe we need to do
something a little more nuanced here
he's no longer part of this thing so
what would be the the true libertarian
view on foreign policy well first of all
anyone that's going to do us harm
whether that's individuals groups
corporations foreign governments that's
a government responsibility to protect
us against those that would do us harm
there is a real Islamic terrorist threat
out there is it best addressed with
military intervention no military
interventions I'm going to say are
making things worse so do we address it
with boots on the ground more bombs more
drone strikes no what we need to do is
cut off the funding in my opinion to the
politics of Islamic extremism which is
Sharia law yeah so you're making the
distinction and this is one of the
things we talk about all the time
between the religious aspect and the
political we are to the death we're
going to fight for religious freedom and
allow religious freedom but we need to
recognize that the politics of Islamic
extremism is Sharia law and it is
absolutely incompatible with the US
Constitution starting with women's
rights yeah so what do you make of some
of our alliances then you know Saudi
Arabia is a great example of this a
country that basically is governed by
Sharia law that women still can't drive
they can sort of vote now I mean there's
a litany of things there they're doing
quite the beheading thing too it's not
just Isis and yet they're one of our
biggest allies so it starts with
awareness I mean we need to bring about
this awareness within the United States
that has not really been clearly defined
and I think this does offer this clear
distinction between the politics of
Islamic extremism Sharia law and freedom
of religion Islam but oh it starts with
awareness and we're not there yeah what
do you make of how generally I feel like
our education system has failed to the
point where people don't understand
basically how government's supposed to
work like when I listen
Trump and I listen to Bernie they're
saying I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do
this or any of the candidates I'm gonna
do this but what they don't realize is
the the executive branch the president
is just supposed to sign things into law
the legislative branch Congress and the
Senate are supposed to make the laws and
the judicial branch posed to make sure
they're legal and I feel like nobody
really understands that we think we're
voting for a president like oh here's
the king here's the dictator right right
yeah - right so so I mean in everything
I say look I want you to I want you to
understand what my positions are on this
issue but the reality is is that
Congress does have to pass these
initiatives and don't discount the power
of the veto it's speaking specifically
about myself as governor of New Mexico
I may have vetoed more legislation than
the other 49 governors in the country
combined really I said no to this
legislation which in my opinion was just
going to add time and money to our lives
and wasn't going to affect our lives in
any way that there would be a political
an attempt to politically address issues
that really weren't addressing the
issues at all yeah but you do draw a
really really important distinction look
we're not electing a dictator we're
electing a president who can sign or
veto but we need to know where that
president is at philosophically and then
not to be discounted is is that the
president the United States governor of
a state administrative Lee runs
government right so there is a there is
a bias if you will toward fiscal
austerity if you have a president who's
going to be fiscally austere as governor
of New Mexico they wouldn't cut
government as much as I wanted so
basically we took the money and we spent
less money than was appropriated and put
the money in the bank right of course my
predecessor then ended up spending at
all but there was money in the bank the
coffers were full right and I left but
that was a promise that I made so a lot
of that has to do with our election
system and how screwed up that is
because in a certain way as a governor
it doesn't
who you to not spend all the money
because you want people to see that
there's a lot of things done whether
they can be paid for or not so you were
putting money away which is great I did
I put the money away and I think people
more than recognize that and when I got
reelected and by the way here's another
silver bullet to the system yeah is term
limits and I'm the best example I can
think of term limits I really enjoyed
the job but I knew that maximum I had
eight years so I kind of pushed the
envelope as much as I possibly could for
four years and then it was Katie bar the
door the last four years because there
was I wasn't going to get reelected
there was no I mean I didn't even have
that opportunity yeah so if term limits
were enacted I think that politicians
would do the right thing as opposed to
whatever it takes to get reelected
because that's really what it's all
about it's a system that people get into
it they've never been involved in it
before it's very alluring and they want
to stay in it at any cost whatsoever so
they sell there they sell their souls to
stay in it yeah not only they sell their
souls I mean they sell everything around
them right everything is crony
capitalism is alive and well that
there's a there's a price for favoritism
and big corporations pay for that and
and it's for sale can you give me an
example of that because I know we talked
about this so in in the case of New
Mexico I remember there was a bill that
came before me for signatures called the
telecommunications telecommunications
Equality Act homes gone competitor
telecommunication competitive act
well it wasn't repetitive at all it it
it Qwest Communications it gave them an
up it gave them more of an upper hand
and they already had and I vetoed the
bill but it was it was labeled
telecommunications competitive
legislation when in fact it wasn't at
all right now were they giving you money
at the same time they weren't giving me
anything but it obviously greased this
through the legislature in New Mexico
sure they greased it yeah so
is there any hope for I think you're
going to say yes because you're running
but is there really any hope for people
with integrity to be in the system so
back to term limits iftar yeah I think
that people get involved in this for all
the right reasons initially I think that
they get involved for the right reasons
doing the right thing well if you had
term limits would you actually sign off
on this
telecommunications bill that I was
talking about if you knew that it really
wasn't the right thing I think you'd
probably say well no I think we'll pass
on that because it's really not fair
yeah
so I know I gotta let you go we did some
work here I think you pushed me a little
bit a little bit further you have a
closing argument well a closing argument
is is there's a website i side with yeah
dot-com it was up last last cycle and
it's like I did about half of it I need
to do the other half to figure it out
but I had another one and I came out and
as of right now I do not believe I'm on
the site because I've recently announced
but I think that within a very short
amount of time I will be on the site and
I think that everyone should get on on
that site answer 36 questions and where
you're at on the issues of the day and I
happen to think that if you would do
that I'm making this pitch if you would
do that I think you're going to find
that you end up being paired up with a
guy named Gary Johnson yeah and then see
what happens well and it's one thing to
philosophically be in line with what
most people think it's another thing to
actually be qualified to be President
United States and that you might
actually do what you say you're gonna do
yeah I'm going to also make that pitch
yeah right so final thought that I'm
gonna let you go is so you were in you
ran as a Republican four years ago I did
and you were in some of the debates and
you know if they I always find them so
ridiculous because they're not really
debates right they're dry pointed
questions or whatever what do we do to
make these debates better because we got
more of them I've been tweeting all of
them I find them infuriating what do we
do to make debate right now I am suing
the presidential debate Commission
people wonder why there's not another
choice well at the heart of this is a
presidential debate Commission the can
tension on our part is if you are on the
ballot in enough states to
mathematically be elected president
shouldn't you be in presidential debates
I think that could be an absolute
GameChanger
we are we're suing the presidential
debate Commission on the grounds of
antitrust the Sherman Act that politics
is a business not much of a stretch and
that they collude with one another to
exclude everybody else that's the
reality and we know it doesn't take very
much to know that because we know that
the the parties the DNC and the RNC are
working directly with the networks to
figure out who they want well and we
actually think that the networks
actually sign documents also to to
collude in this conspiracy if you want
to call it that Wow interesting all
right
it's interest I hope next time you'll
come back and we can do a full hour and
we'll do it on my set and I'm going to
take guy side comm I'll finish it then
I'll let you know that well and wait a
couple days or give me a chance to be
the name that potentially might pop up
fair enough all right well I want to
thank Governor Gary Johnson for joining
me today and you can find out more about
his campaign and probably donate this
probably a donate button on there
probably it probably but we're raising
hundreds of dollars by the way I'll get
it no kidding
Gary Johnson 2016 com all right Thank
You governor thank you